Salut, aujourd'hui on est jeudi.
C'est donc le jour où je parle de ce que je veux.
Ça fait très longtemps que je ne vous ai pas parlé de bouquin.
Pas de bouquin de mentalisme parce que le jeudi, c'est hors-sujet.
Hors-sujet, pas tout à fait parce que je veux vous parler d'un auteur que j'affectionne particulièrement, c'est Bernard Werber.
J'ai rencontré cet auteur, par le biais de ses livres hein uniquement,
dans le début des années 90 quand j'étais au collège.
Il avait sorti un seul livre qui s'appelait Les Fourmis.
A la base, Bernard Werber, c'est un journaliste scientifique.
Et c'est quelqu'un qui a une grande réflexion aussi spirituelle.
Ce qui est très intéressant, c'est qu'il met tout ça à l'intérieur de ses bouquins.
Et en parallèle de ça, c'est un vrai auteur de SF.
Le résultat, ça donne un artiste littéraire vraiment complet.
J'ai jamais été déçu par ce qu'il a produit par la suite à part un livre et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Son dernier bouquin c'est "Le Sixième Sommeil".
Dans la vidéo que j'ai fait sur les rêves lucides, je vous en parlais.
Il y a eu Les Fourmis, le cycle des Fourmis :
Les Fourmis, le Jour des Fourmis, La Révolution des Fourmis
et en parallèle l'Encyclopédie du savoir relatif et absolu et le Livre Secret des Fourmis,
ça se ressemble un petit peu mais ça c'est vraiment des annexes au roman,
ça met en parallèle plusieurs histoires dont principalement
celle d'un groupe d'humains et celle d'un groupe de fourmis.
Dit comme ça, ça parait chelou mais on apprend énormément de choses.
Y a aussi un point commun dans tous ses livres,
c'est qu'il y a toujours une impossibilité qu'il va falloir résoudre,
aussi bien dans l'histoire que par le biais d'une énigme.
Plus tard, il a écrit aussi une pentalogie,
pentalogie, c'est pas un livre sur les pantalon,
Les Thanatonautes, l'Empire des Anges, Nous les Dieux, Le souffle des Dieux et le Mystère des Dieux.
C'est 5 livres dont le point de départ, c'est un groupe de personnes
qui cherchent à explorer la mort, à découvrir ce qu'il y a après la mort.
Et tout ça est imprégné de toutes les religions, de toutes les croyances qu'il y a eu,
de la mythologie, de l'Egypte, de science-fiction,
de réflexions, de choses qu'on apprend sur les autres et sur nous-même.
Et là où il est très malin et c'est un grand auteur,
c'est qu'en plus, on récupère des personnages de l'univers des Fourmis
qui viennent se mêler aux Thanatonautes
pour se retrouver après dans l'Empire des Anges et dans Nous Les Dieux.
En journaliste scientifique, il a écrit aussi sur la science.
Le premier qu'il ait fait dans ce genre là, je crois que c'est Le Père de Nos Pères
donc c'est un bouquin qui traite du chaînon manquant,
et comme souvent dans les livres de Bernard Werber,  il y a deux histoires en parallèle :
celle qui se déroule pendant la préhistoire et celle qui se déroule à notre époque.
Dans le même genre, il a écrit L'Ultime Secret
qui est un livre sur quelqu'un qui a découvert la motivation ultime.
Quelle est la plus grande façon de motiver un être humain.
Y a aussi un côté polar derrière tout ça, un polar de SF.
Mais surtout on cherche quelle est notre propre source de motivation durant le livre,
et encore une fois on apprend beaucoup sur nous-même.
Et toujours dans ce style d'écriture, il a écrit Le Rire du Cyclope
qui est un formidable livre sur le rire : d'où vient le rire
Le pitch du livre qui est très drôle, c'était hyper culotté d'écrire là-dessus, c'est "d'où viennent les blagues ?"
Les blagues, celles que tout le monde connait, les blagues universelles.
Qui les écrit ? D'où est ce qu'elles viennent ? Et déjà est ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui les écrit ?
Pour ceux qui aiment les nouvelles, il a aussi écrit deux livres de nouvelles :
L'Arbre des Possibles et Paradis sur Mesure.
Je suis très friand de nouvelles depuis le jour où j'ai découvert Dino Buzzati et  le livre Le K,
et à cet exercice très compliqué que sont les nouvelles, ils s'en sort extrêmement bien.
Dans certaines nouvelles, on pressent le roman qui peut arriver et c'est ce qui s'est passé avec le Rire du Cyclope.
En autre trilogie, il a écrit aussi Troisième Humanité.
Après, comme autre livre, il y a Le Livre du Voyage qui est un essai très particulier
parce que c'est un livre qui nous parle à nous, au lecteur, directement.
Il a également écrit Nos Amis les Humains qui est une pièce de théâtre,
Le Papillon des Etoiles qui est mon livre préféré.
Autant j'aime vraiment la globalité du travail, les trilogies
autant Le Papillons des Etoiles j'ai dû le lire 3-4 fois en fait tellement il était inspirant et inspiré.
Il se passe sur des centaines et des centaines d'années.
Il y a un rythme dans la progression de l'histoire qui arrive à nous surprendre, qui bouge.
Il y a un rythme aussi dans la temporalité qui est très intéressant.
A un certain point, il m'a fait penser aussi à des scénarios de film comme La Planète des Singes.
Il y a juste un livre, je vous ai dit tout à l'heure, Le Miroir de Cassandre, ça n'a pas marché sur moi.
Je suppose que si quelqu'un ne connaissait pas cet auteur et lisait Le Miroir de Cassandre, il l'adorerait.
Y avait un défaut. J'avais l'impression d'une redondance de tout ce que j'avais pu apprendre,
en dehors de l'histoire en elle-même,
de tout ce que j'avais pu apprendre dans ces autres livres,
que ce soit en terme de réflexion, de culture générale, de concept spirituel.
Je trouvais que c'était une espèce de redondance, de résonance de tout ce que qui existait déjà
même si j'ai bien conscience que pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais lu de Werber,
il doit trouver ce bouquin passionnant puisqu'il reprend tous les concepts qu'on a vu déjà dans les autres livres
J'ai l'impression que cette personne a un projet global derrière tout son univers artistique
de transmission de quelque chose et dans ses livres, j'ai l'impression de le rencontrer lui.
Alors je me suis dit aujourd'hui c'est le jour du hors sujet où je dis ce que je veux
ben je parle de mon auteur préféré.
La plupart des livres que je vous ai cité sauf les très très récents
sont disponibles en livre de poche et se trouvent dans les bibliothèques, dans les médiathèques.
Je suis sûr que dans votre entourage, y a des gens qui lisent du Bernard Werber
et vous pouvez emprunter les livres comme ça pour pouvoir les lire.
C'est pas une vidéo pour vous inciter à les acheter.
Ils se trouvent très facilement, vous pouvez vous les faire prêter j'en suis certain.
Et si vous n'en avez jamais lu et que vous n'êtes pas prêt à partir sur une trilogie ou quelque chose comme ça
lisez le Papillon des Etoiles.
Merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas de laisser un petit commentaire.
Je répondrai à tous les commentaires de la semaine ce week-end.
Ça faisait assez longtemps que je n'avais pas fait une vidéo sur des bouquins.
Je crois que je n'avais pas fait ça depuis le mois de février ou mars.
Donc si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit POUCE EN L'AIR.
Pensez également à vous abonner à la chaine en cliquant sur le petit logo
ou sous la vidéo sur Abonnez-vous
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant  un an
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h. Ciao !